hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and if you follow me on Twitter you
already know it's about to be back to
school for me which means a couple
things one I'm about to be really
frickin busy but also two I'm kind of in
that sort of a reorganization back to
school stage where I'm getting it back
to school apps fired up again I'm
getting the back to school brain fired
up again
so I figured I'd show like what's on my
tech now I was gonna do just like a
what's on my phone video but that's
pretty short I've already done stuff
like that and that is to be honest
pretty similar to the last time I did it
but there are a couple other things that
I'm also going to show what's on my
tablet what's on my computer and
hopefully this will help any of you guys
who are going back school or people who
are just curious about the stuff I use
at the end of summer on a daily basis
also I was gonna say this is this could
be sort of like a tag video even though
maybe not every youtuber is gonna do
what's on their phone video but feel
free to tag your favorite tech people
below if you want to see them make a
video about what's on their tech at
least this time of year anyway I'm gonna
get right into it and i'ma start off
with what is on my phone so the phone
I've been using the most over the past
couple of days / weeks has been the
sandstone black 64 gig oneplus one now I
know there's been a lot of animosity and
people talking about oneplus as a
company after all the crap they've done
in the past couple of weeks but I'm
still supporting CyanogenMod as a
company and I still love what they've
done with the software here so as you
can see on my home screen I really keep
it pretty simple on the phones that I
use everyday only two home screens and
only one widget so as you can see here
this is my sign gin mod 11s home screen
and I keep it pretty similar to stock
Android or what you'd find on Google
Play edition phone or Nexus or something
like that have the dialer hangouts
Phoenix which is the Twitter client I
use that uses this material design look
it's really nice and the camera app for
CyanogenMod and then up here I have some
Google apps that I use the most often in
a folder I have Google Tasks which is
what I use as a to-do list for class
Google keep and the Play Store swiping
over to the right we have the today
calendar widget and this is where you'll
find all of my classes and all of the
things that I have to do that are on my
Google Calendar and of course if you tap
up there you're getting
calendar and you have google play music
and Spotify which are my primary music
listening apps I use Spotify more often
because there's a desktop app and I use
package buddy for shipping and receiving
packages and tracking them and Instagram
which is pretty good for viewing photos
but if I'm going to post them I'm not
going to use an Android device
unfortunately and also do use a Google
Play edition launcher so you can see it
is Austin's birthday as I'm shooting
this happy birthday Austin if this is a
real birthday and I do have a flight
later today so I'm shooting this before
I get on a plane but yeah this is the
simple simple launcher and home screens
that I have on my device now if you saw
my review of the oneplus one you already
know a lot of the apps that I use and
you've probably already seen a bunch of
these but I'll go over them real quick
anyway ask you either premium or Plus
which is great for literally getting
minute by minute predictions for whether
it's going to rain or not which is
actually really useful for figuring out
if you're going to need an umbrella when
you leave next up that's notable is
Android wear which I'm going to be
hopefully pairing with a moto 360 any
day now Motorola audible which I use for
listening to some text books Chrome Beta
which has got some now some sweet
material design looks going on so I love
that and then a whole bunch of other you
know stock stuff the calendar Docs blah
blah blah
Dropbox feedly I use for Keeping Up with
RSS feeds and news swiping over we have
Leo's fortune which is that game that
I've showed a couple of people they all
seem to think it looks awesome
I showed a couple of youtubers all in a
hotel and all of them had the immediate
reaction of wow that looks really good
so I've been playing that for a little
bit I also have this Phillips hue light
controller so anytime I want to change
the color or intensity or on and off of
the lights I have this switch here on my
phone but I mostly use my tablet for
that and of course package buddy again
piano tiles is don't touch the white
tiles app where it's again a super
simple game where all you have to do is
tap the the panels as they go down the
screen and hopefully not touch the white
tiles so here's an example basically see
how fast you can go and it plays piano
notes blah blah blah yeah you've seen
this game before it's in the Play Store
you can check it out if you want and
I'll have a link to a whole bunch of the
stuff I talked about right below I like
but
if you want to check out any of these
things but that's basically it reddit
news pocket the PlayMemories app which I
showed in the arcs 100 review which lets
me directly transfer photos from that
rx100 camera via NFC and Wi-Fi to this
phone I use uber a lot too which is
great the YouTube studio app which is
surprisingly good and useful for what it
does and the actual YouTube app so
that's really what's on my phone it's my
oneplus one it's a 64 gig so I actually
have all of my Spotify music downloaded
so I'm gonna get on a plane and I'm not
going to have any internet connection
but I have all of my tracks readily
available so that's good at least having
64 gigs of storage and with the recent
software update I got this morning
battery life is still great I'm pretty
happy with it and I'm liking the stock
Android feel all right so this is the
tablet of choice it is a hundred twenty
eight gig Wi-Fi only iPad Mini with
Retina display running iOS seven not
eight yet and I have the Smart Cover on
it and this is I guess yeah my most used
tablet at the moment now this is my iOS
homescreen so it's not going to be
nearly as detailed or filled with
widgets or fun launcher stuff as an
Android homescreen would be but I guess
I can just show you what apps I have and
the way they're laid out so I only have
like a couple of folders and two pages
of apps here but the dock here is by far
my most recent and most frequently used
apps so the Google app feedly and pocket
again for news and reading news later
and a web browser Safari alien blue for
reddit and the YouTube app all the time
but outside of that you can see up here
I have the calendar I really don't even
use the calendar app that much I just
have it there because it tells me the
date all the time and I wouldn't see the
date immediately anywhere else so I just
like having a date there simple note for
taking notes dropbox photos I use this
Instagram app once in a while but really
there's also this a flip gram or I guess
pad gram yet pad gram is the app that
it's called that actually has this a
tablet optimized UI for scrolling
through my Instagram feed so I use this
a little bit more often but I usually
don't go on Instagram on my tablet
anyway I have the Twitter app I have the
Gmail app and the app store I don't use
Chrome you notice I have Safari down
here I'd
use Chrome as much as Chrome just isn't
that good yet on the iPad it's installed
but it's not my dock because I don't use
it that much and it's also not my
default web browser but yeah I have the
Facebook app vscocam for editing photos
I wish there was a tablet optimized
version of it but it's a great app and I
use it all the time
the Philips you app which I do use
really often on this device for changing
the lights again I have Philips hue
lights in this room so that happens to
be really convenient and of course I
have a chromecast Hangouts Google Drive
bunch of other Google stuff you might
see here the YouTube capture app in case
for some crazy reason I need to capture
a YouTube video on my tablet hopefully
that never happens and you can see this
this folder I made here I think it's
funny because it's it's just a bunch of
the Apple apps that I don't use and I
don't have any place to put them and
they named it productivity which is
funny because I mean they're not
productivity apps are just Apple apps
but good on you Apple for naming them in
a way that makes me want to check on it
once in a while I have a couple of games
Real Racing 3 I played that once in a
while
NBA 2k14 I play that once in a blue moon
and virtual table tennis which is
actually probably my most played game on
this device Google Maps Google Docs
audible again and that's about it so
yeah there you have my iPad set up again
no fancy launcher tricks or anything
this is iOS 7 I'm not using any of the
beta here but I am using this tablet
quite often simply to consume media
again I use feedly and pocket and
YouTube a lot on this iPad alrighty so
lastly it's the classic in the tech
community anyway it's the what's on my
dock or I guess what's on my computer
video so this is my 2013 Mac Pro you saw
it in the setup tour video if you've
seen that and the two 4k displays
attached I also have a 13 inch retina
MacBook Pro that I showed you in a
previous video and both of these
machines are running Mac OS 10 mavericks
I haven't installed the Yosemite beta
yet but I do plan on upgrading to
Yosemite as soon as it's available so
this is one of the two displays I
actually can't record both of them at
the same time but as you can see I don't
really keep a whole lot on the desktop I
have some folders over on the
for projects I'm working on so I guess
it is your sneak peak and a shortcut to
the 8 terabyte raid array for my
external storage but then other than
that I keep the desktop pretty clean so
I'll link this wallpaper along with all
of the other wallpapers you've seen in
this video we'll have a like button so
here at the bottom is my dock and I've
I've actually accumulated a couple
things in my dock over the over the
course of you know the couple months
I've been using this machine these are
the things I keep here Finers always
they're Chrome I use over Safari Spotify
on a daily basis Adobe Premiere Pages
Keynote and numbers then I have my
Google Tasks app notational velocity is
where I take notes Twitter which is just
the retina Twitter app for Twitter and
then System Preferences the App Store
audacity I happen to be using right now
TextEdit and I'm using QuickTime to
record so these things usually aren't in
the dock and then I have my downloads
Google Chrome and the trash now I
usually have a whole bunch of things
open like I said there are two displays
here on the other display there's a
whole bunch of stuff open but I usually
have just the web browser and whatever
things I'm directly working with on this
monitor and then on the other monitor
I'll have Twitter and Spotify and
notational velocity and Google Tasks and
the things I don't necessarily work on
at the moment but I'm going to go ahead
and swipe in I guess it's not Mission
Control but whatever you want to call
this thing that shows you the apps that
you have shortcutted these are basically
all of the applications I have installed
so you can see all these Apple apps
again they make you put them in folders
so I have two big folders of Apple apps
the adobe extra apps some red apps which
are actually really good red giant which
are apps plug-ins for my Adobe Premiere
video editing software and then the
logitech apps and then here are the rest
of them so chrome again Safari app store
Pages Keynote numbers calculator Dropbox
I use again a whole bunch of these apps
here are all the Adobe suite apps that I
have installed right now so Adobe
Premiere Pro carbon CC 2014 is the video
editing app I use 95% of the time I use
After Effects I guess when I'm feeling
fancy or when I'm doing
specific motion tracking effect
Photoshop is here and Lightroom is here
[ __ ] is also a really awesome app if you
haven't heard of it it's great for it's
basically a free version of Photoshop
it's an image manipulation program and
it's it's pretty impressive audacity for
my audio recording the Google Play Music
manager and player X which is my version
of QuickTime Player except without the
gamma shift so it's a really really good
media player essentially that will play
any format without screwing with your
colors notational velocity for the notes
again Google keep Skype which I just
about never used I stat menus and I'll
show you I start and then use because
ice time I use is really cool up here at
the top you can see the temperature and
the different measurements of the cores
and all the resources I'm using on this
Mac Pro all of that is from AI stat
menus so you can check that out just by
googling it or it's in the App Store if
you want to check that out what else is
here CyanogenMod installer very popular
CCleaner
classic and the unarchive ER for
unzipping huge files when i'm sharing
them that's about it so that's what's on
my Mac that's what's on my iPad and that
is what is in my dock that's what's on
my phone that's about it so again thank
you for watching if you enjoyed this
video four-figure give it a thumbs up
below and if you want to leave a comment
asking for someone else to do a video
like this feel free to do that too
there's a subscribe button below if you
haven't already click that that'll get
you early to see these videos as soon as
they come out thank you for watching
happy birthday Austin and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace